ein Tag essen für 100 Euro mehr guckt
euch das mal an
guckt ihn euch an 5 Euro das kleine
Gläschen aber das wird uns Geschmack
ohne Ende geben
ich checke gerade nicht dass wir das für
diese 100 € heute bekommen ne wir haben
bereits 1,5 Euro 10 Euro 20 Euro 50 Euro
und jetzt ein 100 € Budget für einen
gesamten Tag in dem Fall vollgenuss ich
bin mir eigentlich sicher dass uns heute
nichts anderes erwarten wird als sehr
sehr besondere Lebensmittel gutes Essen
gute Zeit und Luxus weil 100 Euro an
einem Tag für Essen auszugeben ist ein
absoluter Luxus ihr habt euch gewünscht
dass wir häufiger kochen das haben wir
gemacht einmal essen gegangen sind wir
trotzdem kann Euch so viel sagen es ist
schon fast alles möglich wenn man 100 €
zur Verfügung hat deshalb freut Euch auf
das Video schaut wie wir das Geld
ausgegeben haben und seht vor allem was
für unfassbar leckere Dinge wie heute
essen durften
[Musik]
25 auf Frühstück 17 Euro Abendessen
bisher ich glaube das wird ein krankes
Mittagessen
[Musik]
so kann man auf jeden Fall in den Tag
starten das hier ist mein Einkauf fürs
Frühstück wir machen Blini mit Creme
fraiche mit Dill mit Lachs und mit
Kaviar zumindest mit sowas ähnlichem
vikaria richtiger Kaviar ist heute noch
out of budget aber das hier ist Heide
Forellenkaviar Stör Kaviar kostet
irgendwie 80 Euro oder so in hoher
Qualität in einem kleinen Gefäß
dementsprechend sind wir heute noch
nicht ganz am Maximum aber wir sind auf
einem sehr sehr guten Weg insgesamt hat
der Einkauf 25,18 gekostet und ich
konnte wirklich komplett sorglos
Einkaufen also ich habe eingekauft als
hätte ich gar keine budget-beschränkung
biolax Bio-Eier eigentlich alles so ohne
Kompromisse einfach ich glaube wir
werden auch viel Spaß beim Kochen haben
deshalb fangen wir genau damit an wir
bereiten einmal alles vor dann legen wir
los hier haben wir alle Zutaten so sieht
das ganze ausgepackt aus und wir können
loslegen den habe ich jetzt ungefähr
eine Stunde lang getrunken wir brauchen
einen Schneebesen wir machen jetzt einen
Teig und wir nehmen uns eine Schüssel
geben beide Mehle wir haben einmal
Buchweizenmehl und einmal Weizenmehl
geben wir in eine Schüssel und wir das
ganze jetzt habe ich hier hinten im Ofen
es ist eine Schande aber ich habe keine
Mikrowelle ihr kennt die Küche wisst wie
schön sie ist aber ich habe mir einfach
keine Mikrowelle rein konfiguriert weil
ich dachte so ja wer braucht schon eine
Mikrowelle aber zum Milch war machen und
Butter schmelzen ist eine Mikrowelle
super wir brauchen nämlich geschmolzene
Butter und lauwarme Milch dann brauchen
wir ein Zehntel von einem Block Hefe die
gebe ich jetzt leicht gebröselt in die
lauwarme Milch hinein die lösen wir
darin auf
cool wie schaumig die Milch wird Alter
das geben wir zu unserer Mehlmischung
wie schaumig das geworden ist und dazu
kommt jetzt noch unsere geschmolzene
Butter jetzt verrühren wir das zu einem
glatten Teig so einfach kann es manchmal
sein ne lachkick war in dem Rezept dass
ich gefunden habe stand dann so mit
eisgekühltem Wodka oder Champagner
genießt zum Frühstück einfach wenn das
glatt gerührt ist geben wir ein Ei und
ein Eigelb hinzu und das zugehörige
Eiklar schlagen wir jetzt steif ich bin
sehr gespannt habt ihr die Post
steif geschlagen das hier mische ich
jetzt noch unter und dann heben wir
vorsichtig unser Eiweiß drunter und
lassen das Ganze dann für 30 Minuten
stehen schön aus sieht richtig aus ne so
schön flüssig
von Hand dann noch eine kleine Prise
Salz
und so heben wir das Ganze unter
der Teig ist jetzt eine halbe Stunde
gegangen und wirft wunderbare Bläschen
freue mich sehr darauf sage ich euch wie
es ist und unsere Aufgabe ist es jetzt 5
cm große kleine große kleine Blinis zu
backen bisschen Butter auf der planscher
wenn der erste jetzt klappt wäre krass
eigentlich klappt nie der erste bei
irgendwas ne ich dachte ja immer das
sind einfach ganz normale so Pfannkuchen
Mini Pfannkuchen ja wer weiß vielleicht
ist oder ein geiler Pancake Teig
jetzt brauchen wir Geduld dann schauen
wir mal drunter
[Musik]
schauen wir hier mal drunter
wie schön Farbe bekommen perfekt
durchgebacken genauso machen wir es
jetzt auch von der anderen Seite und
dann richten wir an
ein finishing touch fehlt noch frischer
Schnittlauch Name mehr guckt euch das
mal an ich bin sehr sehr zufrieden mit
unserem Ergebnis zu ein zwei von diesen
Nocken sauerrahm-nocken sind mir
gelungen ja jetzt kommt auf den
Geschmack an 25 Euro kostet das muss ich
selbst zu kochen ich bin gespannt keine
Ahnung so was ihr sagt dazu ist das
komplett bescheuert oder kann man sich
das an einem besonderen Tag mal gönnen
wir gehen auf jeden Fall jetzt in
luxuriöse Gebiete ich nehme hier mal so
einen frischen Blini der ist noch
lauwarm diese Nocke Creme fraîche oben
drauf sagt auf jeden Fall das ist kein
rein gesundes Frühstück ist aber ich
finde man merkt man ist was Besonderes
oder man hat was Besonderes vor sich ich
möchte das ganz probieren
es schmeckt einfach fein also es ist
auch einfach eine besondere Kreation so
ich finde so diese
üppige Creme fraiche so gibt einem so
das Gefühl so boah sowas richtig so das
was fettiges aber der hat trotzdem so
eine ganz elegante Komponente so durch
den Kaviar der Geräusch hatte Geschmack
vom Lachs ist super so die frischen
Kräuter geben auch eine Komponente mit
rein und die frisch gebackenen
gamechanger
absoluter Luxus der nur dank unseres
Budgets möglich ist worüber ich mich
sehr freue dass es nicht weniger
luxuriös wird es wird nicht weniger
besonders ich glaube ich verdrückt das
Frühstück chillen bisschen und dann
machen wir uns auf den Weg zu unserem
Mittagessen zu einem Sternerestaurant
jo was man ganz kurz für dieses Budget
auch noch mal festhalten muss ist das
hier jetzt sieben Leute davon wieder
essen ja so wie immer kaufen wir ein für
das Geld was im Titel steht weil so nach
unserer Auffassung ist das das einzige
was wirklich funktioniert bei so einer
Budget Challenge klar man kann
runterrechnen aber da würden wir bei 100
€ schon bague und sonst was essen alle
Essen davon und einen schmeckt es
hoffentlich nein
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wir haben uns hier schon einen edlen
Tropfen aufgemacht wir bleiben natürlich
weiterhin im Budget 8,50 € für eine
Flasche Sprudelwasser das ist normal in
edlen Restaurants und man sieht im
Hintergrund das ist nicht irgendeins
hier waren wir mit dem Restaurant
Kritiker wer erinnert sich an diesen
Mann ich bin ganz froh dass wir hier
gemeinsam sitzen und so vegan sich
endlich wieder gekreuzt und heute
erklärst du mir wie du arbeitest hier
haben wir einiges über Wein und Käse
gelernt von Maximilian Lorenz selbst
Wein ist ein scheiß teures Hobby war ja
es schmeckt auch teuer die habe ich
einen Tag Praktikum in der Sterneküche
gemacht
drei zwei
das finde ich an meinem ersten Tag als
Praktikant heute als Gast freue ich mich
auch das Business Lunch Mittagsmenü zu
genießen hier im Heinz Hermann der Laden
ist ja zweigeteilt Sterneküche und
Weinlokal wir trinken zwar kein Wein
aber wir essen frische Spaghetti mit
rinderfiletspitzen Kirschtomaten ich
glaube das wird richtig gut vorher noch
einen feinen Salat rote Beete Walnüsse
ich freue mich auf das was auf uns
zukommt aber in dem Ambiente hier kann
es eigentlich nur gut gehen Post Minion
wir waren zu lange nicht mehr ein
Sternerestaurant
also dieses so sich so zurücklehnen und
chillen nicht mehr oder ja ich bin froh
dass wir dieses Business Lunch
wahrnehmen können weil mit zwei mal
kochen werden wir glaube ich im
Abendgeschäft
hätten wir es vielleicht knapp geworden
aber wie Dankeschön die suvit gegarte
rote Beete sieht auf jeden Fall
besonders aus habe ich so noch nie
gesehen dieser Cracker oben drauf ist
scheinbar auch aus Walnuss gebacken der
Väter sieht irgendwie weicher aus als
das was man so im Supermarkt bekommt ich
bin gespannt wie die Konsistenz ist die
Kräuter sind toll und das sind ja meine
Kollegen da drin ne die können das halt
ne erinnert euch
ich checke gerade nicht dass wir das für
diese 100 € bekommen ne das fühlt sich
schon wieder an wie komplette Erlebnis
hier gerade oder
[Musik]
das ist so außerhalb so von so einem der
normalen Geschmackserlebnisse aber super
frisch auch perfekt für so ein Lunch so
weil du hast die Tagen vor dir und das
hier ist ja wirklich super easy
superleicht dann kann man das mit der
Hauptspeise auch noch machen aber ich
weiß gar nicht ich erkenne die Gewürze
gar nicht deshalb kann ich schlecht
erklären aber schmeckt so super so süß
abgerundet cremig mit dem Väter also ist
sehr sehr lecker ich bin gespannt wie
die Hauptspeise wird okay super danke
schön
eingelegten Tomaten
nee wie geil ist das für 30 €, das ist
so ein nicer Valley von money mit der
Vorspeise noch und die Größe der Portion
also dieser parmesanschaum der steht ja
quasi richtig im Teller man sieht auch
dass er sich in den Nudeln schon
festgesogen hat paar von den
Rinderfiletstreifen sind auch dabei
schöne Tomaten
[Musik]
wieder sitzen die Leute draußen uns
wieder dafür also super lecker ich kann
nicht so salzig und dominant wie man
sich vorstellen kann würde ich ein
bisschen flüssiger als man vielleicht
denkt das aber super weil sonst wäre das
ja viel zu massiv das Essen rinderfile
ich meine Rinderfilet ne dann geht auch
nicht viel ja und wenn man sich jetzt
mal die Portionsgröße anschaut das sind
bestimmt 130 150 Gramm ja auf jeden Fall
bei 38,50 € Wasserflasche und Menü wir
haben aber ja eigentlich so eine echte
Auszeit vom Tag dafür komplett wir haben
absolut genießen können feinste Zutaten
und man merkt auf jeden Fall 100 € für
einen Tag das ist absoluter Luxus bin
froh dass sie das heute machen kann
deswegen auch vielen Dank an euch wenn
ihr mich bei sowas unterstützen wollt
könnt ihr auch einfach ein kostenloses
Abo da lassen aber ich glaube wir gucken
mal besser was ich noch mit dem Restgeld
kochen kann wir genießen das ganze hier
und dann sehen wir uns zum Abendessen
und wir kommen zum Abendessen es wird
eben nicht minder luxuriös wir haben
wirklich eine tolle Sache vor uns das
hier ist Risottoreis das hier ist
Kabeljau das hier ist Safran guckt ihn
euch an 5 Euro das kleine Gläschen aber
das wird uns Geschmack ohne Ende geben
unser Kabeljau den werden wir ganz
einfach zubereiten 5 Euro hat uns dieses
wunderbare Stücke kostet das geben wir
jetzt in den Backofen nicht in
irgendeinen sondern in unseren
Dampfbackofen und da braucht das was
hieß es noch mal ungefähr so eine halbe
Stunde ungefähr eine halbe Stunde komm
zack das ist das Einzige was wir damit
machen müssen hat schon hat doch was
cooles und Dampfbackofen wir kümmern uns
um unsere Risotto wir brauchen einen
Topf schön hier so auf mittlerer Hitze
dann geben wir unsere Schalotten rein
wir machen die Sounds einfach selbst
nicht reicht wir dünsten unsere
Schalotten ein bisschen an wenn den
kleinen Vorsprung haben geben wir den
Knoblauch dazu wenn das ein bisschen
angedünstet ist nehmen wir unseren
Risotto weiß 200 Gramm und geben ihn
dazu und schwitzen den einfach mal schön
mit an der wird einfach so mit
angeröstet angeschwitzt zurzeit
abzulöschen erstmal mit Weißwein
und wenn der verkocht ist gebe ich noch
ein bisschen Orangensaft dazu man sieht
schon richtig das wird jetzt auch schon
so langsam so ein bisschen schlotzig die
Stärke aus dem Reis tritt aus jetzt
kommt unser Orangensaft zum Einsatz
ich kann mir vorstellen dass die süße
darin auch so ein bisschen
karamellisiert oder ich glaube auch dass
das echt eine super Sache ist also das
war jetzt einfach frei Schnauze dass wir
das nur mit Orangensaft gemacht haben
aber es kann nicht schlecht sein
eigentlich und jetzt kommt unsere
Hühnerbrühe rein 400 ml auf 200 ml
Risottoreis oder jetzt ist es nur noch
gelegentliches rühren man muss wirklich
nicht die ganze Zeit durchgehen können
so dass man das jetzt einfach ein
bisschen Quellen damit das Ganze aber
auch schon ordentlich durch den Safran
aromatisiert wird gebe ich davon jetzt
schon ein bisschen rein ich will schon
dass das ordentlich schmeckt ich habe 5
€ für den Spaß bezahlt die Hälfte davon
ist das vielleicht zack gehen wir dazu
wir warten jetzt dass der Risotto Reis
die Hühnerbrühe aufsaugt und ab dann
tweaken wir dann noch so ein bisschen
die Konsistenz 15 Minuten sind vergangen
Karma umgerührt das ganze sieht schon
schön schlotzig aus aber richtig
losgehen tut es erst wenn jetzt Parmesan
und Butter hinzufügen ich nehme erstmal
die kalte Butter hier geht auch nicht
wenig oder nicht wenig 40 g sind das
gebe ich hier so dazu rühre die jetzt
hier langsam unter ich halte mich jetzt
noch zurück mit nachsalzen oder pfeffern
oder irgendwas weil der Parmesan
natürlich gleich Salz mitbringt auch der
macht's nur besser also auch wenn wir da
Parmesan hinzufügen so das soll
passieren das wird dann noch cremiger
herzhafter käsiger das das schon eine
geile Sache wie viel haben wir
ausgegeben alles bis auf 48 Cent das
heißt im Umkehrschluss
99,52 Euro krass
[Musik]
Mama mir das sieht wirklich super gut
aus also ich bin sehr zufrieden ich
würde hier noch ein zwei drei
Cherrytomaten sehen aber ja nur noch 48
Cent übrig es riecht aber unfassbar gut
glaub wir sollten probieren
und jetzt zieht sich so schön
auseinander ist innen drin sehr schön
glasig
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass diese eine
Saft orange so viel Geschmack gibt dann
das Risotto Safran und Orange perfekt
zusammen das Risotto ist einfach man
sieht das richtig ne also guck mal
sowieso die einzelnen Körner ineinander
verschmilzen und Sorten genauso fühlt
sich es auch im Mund also so richtig
schön schlotzig dazu dieser glasige
Fisch passt perfekt so also perfekt
Harmonie das Gericht soll nicht perfekt
aber es ist sehr sehr sehr sehr gut und
halt auch wieder maximum seriös ne
Safran Kabeljau was willst du eigentlich
mehr
egal was wir heute gekocht haben es sah
verdammt gut aus und eine Sache ist
wesentlich mitverantwortlich dafür wie
Essen für uns wirkt wie es aussieht so
wie sehr es uns optisch anspricht und
das ist das Geschirr auf dem es steht
oder liegt oder was auch immer ihr habt
vielleicht gemerkt wir haben
wunderschönes Geschirr hier bei uns im
Büro und haben dann eine Zusammenarbeit
mit Motel amio und ich bin wirklich sehr
sehr sehr dankbar darüber weil guckt
euch das mal an so im in der alten Küche
in meiner normalen Küche habe ich
einfach so stinknormales langweiliges
weißes Geschirr und es war von Anfang an
klar wir wollen Geschirr haben dass das
gekochte hervorhebt und finde das
Geschirr von Mutter Mio ist wunderschön
und gerade sowas hier so gelbe Sachen
Risotto auf so einem blauen Teller der
noch eine Struktur hat so das sieht
einfach direkt viel besser aus deshalb
Dankeschön an Nutella Mio und es gibt
auch wirklich ein sehr sehr gutes
Angebot für euch und zwar könnt ihr mit
dem Code Motel Max 30% auf eure
Bestellung sparen das ist sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr gut also man kann selten so
viel Geld bei den sparen vollkommener
Luxus 100 € für einen Tag auszugeben ist
mir ganz bewusst aber man kann auch
unfassbar leckere Sachen dafür Essen
danke was dazu gesehen hat ihr könnt
liebend gerne das für euch
vorgeschlagene Videos schauen oder aber
auch den Kanal abonnieren oder beides
also noch besser wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Mal wieder bis dahin und